the villain of this documentary is is
Jerry Krause who was the GM of the Bulls
yeah now the the owner of the Bulls is
Jerry Reinsdorf
yes I'm assuming at the time Jerry was
the owner and president meaning the
president of a team handles things that
are not only basketball related but just
all things related with the team right
the GM handles only the basketball side
of things right so a GM will obviously
the president has say yeah he signs off
on the decisions of the GM but the GM is
like who's gonna coach who we gonna get
to play on the team etc I believe the
president is not only all those things
but also how are we gonna market the
team how we're gonna you know find ways
to sell [ __ ] jerseys what are we gonna
do for these that there are other things
that are involved with the president
so Krause is I guess the villain here
Krause is very interesting and kind of
unfairly painted in my opinion kind of
at best I think okay we'll go into it
yes you tell me what now I'm curious to
know why you think what was unfair and I
think I know but I'm still curious the
biggest knock on Krauss yeah is in my
opinion the biggest thing you could take
away from Krauss is he didn't draft
Jordan okay so the lynchpin for all the
all the other decisions that he made is
Jordan right
he is the core of that team he's what
makes that team win he's the engine that
makes the car drive yeah you've still
got to build a team around him yes
Jordan didn't win before Krause yes
right yeah like he had other people on
that team he had other coaches but they
couldn't get the job done granted he was
much younger maybe he would develop into
the 85-86 he came like right after
Jordan but yeah yeah it was after but he
didn't draft Jordan right right
which is very important he's a really
interesting character because he comes
from baseball who
where he was asked out and then just
asked Jerry Reinsdorf Jerez was also on
the baseball team he was a scout for
yeah I think he's a soms can I can I be
GM now back in a day scouting was like
the pinnacle yeah that's what mattered
so if you were good Scout I guess that
meant that you could be good at being a
GM apparently and I was asking around a
bit yesterday Krause was way ahead of
his time in terms of analyzing talent
hmm now here's the thing that people
don't get a GM's job is not to analyze
superstars anybody can save it Giannis
antetokounmpo isn't drafting so you see
it before they have it and role players
that's the skill of GM makes is finding
role players that fit with your
superstars anybody can tell you Shaq is
gonna do well Kobe's gonna do well Kawhi
is gonna do well right how do you find
Ron Harper right how do you get a 20
point per game score before he comes to
the Bulls right and know he's gonna fit
in that system how do you find Toni
Kukoc how do you find a Pippin how do
you make the trade for Pippen right you
know who we traded for Pippen no know
one of the greatest players in the
history of the game Scottie Pippen was
traded for a guy we don't [ __ ] know
right right seeing that talent yeah
right so he had an undeniable ability to
find out he was one of the first guy to
get into analytics things that people do
now wingspan hands sighs hmm
shuttle drills closing speed right not
you know what I mean like really getting
into the almost like NFL type combine
right [ __ ] to truly analyze players and
looking for an advantage anywhere he
possibly could right
the problem is in what the documentary
shows is ego yes now here's the thing
about ego ego is not a one way street
usually yeah ego is a pinball machine an
ego because Mario ego began
or right right so when you have one ego
fighting against another that is what
causes the meltdown one ego is fine
three four five egos that's when [ __ ]
starts to become troubling and what we
were looking at when we're looking at
the Bulls is we're looking at a
displacement of credit right and that's
where people get upset it's not just
Jorden getting the credit Krauss can
live with Jordan getting the credit it's
still getting credit right Krauss is
going nobody would know who Phil Jackson
was if I didn't find him nobody would
know who Scottie Pippen was if I ain't
trade for maybe they would nobody would
know who Toni Kukoc was if I didn't go
get him nobody would know Dennis Rodman
well yes they would but nobody would
have given Dennis Rodman another chance
if I didn't come in there and do it
right so he really did orchestrate this
team Phil's getting all the credit
obviously Jordans getting the credit but
he's not getting credit and when there's
that displacement Eagle you got him
coming out and you got him going I want
mine the problem with Jerry Krause is
that he'd never really experienced not
having a Jordan and at the end of the
day a Jordan is what makes [ __ ] move
yeah you are nothing without the George
exactly it's easy to have ego when
you've only experienced good times
you've always been with a Jordan because
you start going well I built it with
Jordan I'll build it with someone else
I built this team I could do it right
when Phil and the in Jordan dig their
heels into the mud or whatever that
[ __ ] saying is and say now we're
doing this this is our last dance
the only equal opposite reaction of that
for a Jerry Krause is yeah it is yours
I'm blowing this thing up and I'm gonna
redo it without you guys to prove I can
do it you don't think Bill Belichick is
trying to win this here so oh yeah damn
right he is the two biggest and you can
maybe argue the bigger problem is
Reinsdorf
but Jerry Krause anybody who says he's
an idiot he's not a good GM I can
dismiss that person yeah your fatal flaw
is like you said ego if I if I make
millions of dollars in building
mansion cool I did that if I burn the
[ __ ] down and lose all my money
I'm an idiot yes there is I don't care
if I made the money and got the
management I don't care if Jerry Krause
put the places in there you have won
five straight championships and you tell
the coach you're not coming back I don't
give a [ __ ] if you go 82 and oh yeah
you're not coming back this is your last
year yeah that is pure ego you're
burning the house down and for that it
you are the villain 100% you just are
the villain everything is a battle of
egos greatness if you're not as great as
Jordan or Phil and a GM and particular
greatness is saying okay I will swallow
my ego mm-hmm and if you can't swallow
your your ego Eimi amidst greater people
with bigger egos you're that's not a
talent especially not for GM who by
nature is behind the scenes is is Phil
in Jordan not great by that definition
[Applause]